[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur France 24 notre invité aujourd'hui
est Mirail low podolia que c'est un
conseiller du président ukrainien
volodime ski et il est avec nous depuis
la capitale ukrainienne qui est merci
beaucoup monsieur podeliac
oui bonjour Alors Kiev justement a été à
nouveau bombardé cette nuit ça fait
plusieurs jours de suite que se
passe-t-il en ce moment à Kiev monsieur
podeliac
si je ne me trompe pas la cinquième
attaque depuis une semaine et demi la
nuit du 7 au 8 nous avons subi une
attaque par drone 35 drones ont attaqué
qui cette nuit
missiles X1 x105 on était tirés sur Kiev
à ce jour-là majorité de ces missiles
ont été abattus mais il y a eu plusieurs
cas de chute de débris sur des maisons
privées sans beaucoup de victimes en
tout cas nous voyons nous observons que
la nuit du 8 au 9 mai Moscou a
activement attaqué et vous pouvez
comprendre la logique aujourd'hui nous
allons avoir sur une tribune sur la
Place Rouge les politicus qui vont
l'anniversaire de la victoire de 1945
est tout en même temps ils attaquent qui
Ève une ville Pacifique alors justement
ce 9 mai il y a donc le défilé
traditionnel pour célébrer la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale à Moscou le
président Poutine s'est exprimé il a
taffé que c'était un tournant et que le
peuple ukrainien est otage d'un régime
criminel guidé par ces maîtres
occidentaux que vous inspire à la fois
ce défiler et ses paroles de Vladimir
Poutine
tout d'abord il faut bien
mettre les choses il faut mettre les
points sur lesquels parade de la
victoire un jour où la Russie mène une
guerre contre la population civile d'un
pays souverain première chose donc
deuxième chose il faut comprendre que
n'importe quelle guerre et la deuxième
guerre mondiale était l'une des plus
cruelles du 20e siècle et peut-être de
l'histoire un jour de fin de guerre
c'est un jour de mémoire un jour de
recueillement donc c'est un concevable
que les politiques réunissent et parlent
de attaquer comme le font aujourd'hui
les politiques et russes et une chose
que je à laquelle je voudrais attirer
votre attention et l'attention des
Occidentaux la Russie quand elle célèbre
la victoire du mec en 1945 c'est avec le
sourire et en disant nous pouvons le
répéter donc je vous laisse réfléchir à
ce que cela
quant aux paroles de Monsieur Poutine
c'est très étrange je les trouve très
étrange il y a un État souverain à la
Russie un autre État souverain l'Ukraine
et je trouve étrange que l'investisse
permet de commenter les problèmes
internes au Ukraine nous n'avons pas de
coup d'état et si il y avait un régime
qui ne respectait pas les droits de
l'homme la population aurait protesté
notamment elle aurait protesté aux urnes
lors d'élection pour préserver la
démocratie dans le pays et ce n'est
certainement pas la Russie qui devrait
s'ingérer dans les affaires de l'Ukraine
enfin quatrième point
la situation est la suivante la Russie
c'est toujours considéré endroit de
s'immiscer dans la politique interne
d'autres pays voisins notamment celle de
l'Ukraine la Russie a commencé une
guerre à grande échelle contre l'Ukraine
pour changer le pouvoir dans notre pays
c'est en réalité la seule cause de cette
guerre et nous sommes en guerre depuis
15 mois aujourd'hui
une guerre qui n'a aucune autre
justification une guerre lancée par les
fédérations de Russie qui n'a aucune
justification aucune cause et non
nous ne pouvons pas accepter les paroles
de Monsieur Poutine qui
justifie les meurtres de civil dans le
pays voisin alors évidemment on parle
beaucoup de la préparation d'une
contre-offensive
ukrainienne votre ministre de la défense
estime que les attentes des alliés
occidentaux sont peut-être exagérés
c'est sa principale crainte qu'après la
contre-offensive qu'on a vu à l'automne
dans la région de harkis dans la région
de Kerson les Ukrainiens pourraient
reprendre tous les territoires qui ont
été conquis par la Russie est-ce que
vous aussi vous pensez que les
Occidentaux mettent peut-être trop de
pression sur l'Ukraine pour réussir et
réussir vite
donc nos partenaires occidentaux ne sont
pas trop optimistes je pense qu'ils sont
tout à fait réalistes et comprennent
qu'une guerre à rallonge ne profite qu'à
la Russie si on baisse
d'intensité et sur le champ de bataille
cela permettra à l'armée russe de se
regrouper de se préparer donc pour
éviter que la Russie est le temps
d'accumuler des armements moderniser ces
armements et mobiliser des soldats il
faut avancer le plus vite possible il
faut terminer la guerre le plus vite
possible quand au terme contrefens
attaque qui commençait aujourd'hui qui
est terminée quatre jours plus tard
c'est beaucoup d'activités sur des
terrains différents qui ont pour but
principal de percer le front à peser
endroit donc ce qui nous intéresse c'est
de libérer nos territoires seulement une
sortie sur les frontières de 1991
permettront également à la Russie de
entamer une transformation
politique interne et abandonné les
aspirations revenchistes nous comprenons
donc que la contrepensive c'est des
dizaines des centaines d'activités qui
peuvent prendre un certain temps il ne
s'agit pas d'une opération d'un de jour
3 jours ou une semaine
grâce aux ressources que nous avons
accumulé grâce à l'aide de nos
partenaires grâce à la préparation des
unités ukrainiennes nous pourrons
débloquer certains territoires de
manière efficace d'un point de vue
[Musique]
la manière dont nous évoluons le moral
d'être brusques 3
défaites de trois défaites stratégiques
peuvent renverser la motivation de des
militarus et les faire abandonner le
champ de bataille c'est une des un des
scénarios plausibles de l'évolution
est-ce que cette contre-offensive vous
avez dit il y aura de multiples facettes
est-ce que ça va aussi évidemment
concerner le don basse voir la Crimée
les scénarios
que nous avons préparés
sont connus que du de l'état-major et du
président et qui sont évidemment au
courant de tous les scénarios qui sont
préparés ceux qui font comprendre ce
qu'il est important de comprendre la
déoccupation de nos territoires sans
déoccupation des territoires
occupés depuis 2014 cela ne permettrait
pas de terminer la guerre donc d'une
autre plan stratégique de contre iPhone
6 inclut la libération de la presqu'île
de Crimée et des parties du gambas
occupé en 2014 c'est important que vous
le compreniez une contrefensive et
efficace permettra de baisser le moral
des trucs russes forcer les forcer à
abandonner leur position notamment au
Crimée et je l'espère entamer certaines
transformations politiques en Russie ce
qui permettra à terme de
revoir le format de la sécurité en
Europe si l'élite en Russie reste la
même et il va continuer à investir dans
le chantage terroriste
un meurtre politique
financé des mouvements radicaux en
Europe pour des provocations afin de
pouvoir dominer en Europe c'est une
guerre une guerre en temps réel qui
montre que la Russie est indifférente au
droit international en tant que tel et
il faut donc terminer cette guerre de la
bonne manière dernière question est
gagnée Prigogine le chef de Wagner fait
des déclarations presque quotidiennes il
a accusé
l'état-major russe de ne pas lui fournir
de munitions menacées de quitter la
ville de barmouth où il y a une bataille
terrible depuis des mois et ce 9 mai il
accuse tout simplement les chefs
militaires russes je le cite de tromper
Vladimir Poutine et que l'État russe est
incapable de défendre la Russie
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
déclarations
prigognes qu'est-ce que ça signifie sur
la situation peut-être de l'élite au
pouvoir en Russie
premièrement évidemment cela est un
reflet de la situation au sein des
élites russes c'est une
des incarnations de ce conflit entre
deux groupes différents dans les élites
entre Shugo et guérir ministre et chef
de l'état-major donc entre ce tandem là
et privilégie il y a un conflit depuis
un an environ car le ministère de la
Défense veut réduire le poids de Wagner
dans la prise de décision donc Wagner ne
reçoit pas de livraison
ne reçoit pas de recrues on lui a
interdit de recruter dans les prisons
comme il faisait on a coupé ses budgets
et derrière lui en seconde ligne il y a
des unités de Mée régulière qui ne lui
permettront pas de quitter le champ de
bataille donc pris d'origine comprend
très bien cela et il est très
mécontent du fait que ces soldats sont
tués et certains sont transférés vers
des unités de l'armée régulière donc
cela est un des aspects des conflits qui
existent dans les élites si nous
arrivons à obtenir des défaites
importantes de l'armée russe c'est
conflits dans les élites ne vont
qu'augmenter Mirail merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu aux questions de France
24 depuis qui est la capitale
ukrainienne et merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cet entretien sur nos antennes
[Musique]